I'm originally from the northern Nigeria  but six years ago and move for Kaduna to  pursue my music career Wow  Karuna is a big city where the music  industry moved better than any other  state in the country so this is it  welcome to our house we arrived to  Katonah has been takes me to where him  and his roommates live Wow  like it it looks so different in person  this is the kitchen  okay this is our room  Wow how do all three of you guys sleep  in this tiny little room no culture is  normal you just your old man your guys  no problem  hmm this is a child's bed hmm maybe love  this is the bathroom  this is it this bucket Jason is going to  bath you from head to toe  no it will not husband's home does not  feel like a celebrity is home to me at  all  seeing the conditions that they live in  it's not what I pictured  I thought you fully now too closer than  you'd like thank God we're staying at  Hotel  [Music]